combien d'entre vous ont déjà été au
musée
merci
combien pense que la culture a ce
pouvoir de changer notre vision au monde
combien ne comprennent rien à l'art
contemporain
vous avez ici une sculpture de felix
gonzalez-torres artistes cubains
alors c'est vrai qu'au premier abord
vous pourriez me dire c'est ça la un tas
de bonbons monfils aurait pu faire la
même chose quand on creuse un peu on se
rend compte que cette culture est en
quelque sorte son autoportrait il
représente son poids en bonbons il parle
ici de la proclamation de la propagation
du virus du sida
donc il a subi les conséquences il
invite le spectateur à prendre un bonbon
un peu comme si le contaminer
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'art et
tout particulièrement du muy mots le
premier musée mobile d'art contemporain
qui va à la rencontre des enfants dans
les villes les campagnes les banlieues
pour un premier contact avec la ce ne
sont pas les enfants qui vont au musée
mais le musée qui vient à eux nous avons
parcouru sept pays sommes allés à la
rencontre de plus de cent vingt deux
mille enfants dont 70 % n'avaient jamais
été au musée
alors comment j'en suis arrivée là je
suis originaire de touraine
issu d'une famille où la culture était
peu présente
on m'a plutôt poussé dans les études
pour faire une carrière dans le sport
les voyages à l'âge de 19 ans je n'ai
toujours pas mis les pieds au musée
je suis à paris à saint germain je me
balade je vois une boutique qui en fait
est une galerie
je rentre c'est une exposition de
l'artiste gérard schloesser artistes
français la figuration narrative
je commence à discuter avec les gens
l'artiste et sa femme nous quitterons
plus jamais il va m'initier à ce monde
du sensible me faire lire beckett en est
à l'opéra au théâtre et bien sûr visité
de nombreuses expositions dans les
musées et centres d'art ma vision sur le
monde va commencer à changer
de par mon éducation j'ai monté une
société de cosmétiques je fais du
trading
entre la france et la chine je commence
à passer plus de temps dans les ateliers
d'artistes que dans les usines
un jour je suis à taipei à taiwan chaque
année je négocie avec mes fournisseurs
et cette année je lui dis voilà je
négocie pas et cet argent
j'aimerais que tu leur as investissent
dans les conditions de vie et travail
des salariés il me regarde
il rigole et là il me dit ingrid hayes
think it's time for you to stop business
est en fait il avait raison cette phrase
va faits remontent en écho en moi et à
partir de ce moment je vais continuer le
monde des affaires mais je vais
commencer à entreprendre différentes
entreprises dans la je vais publier un
magazine d'art contemporain produire des
émissions télé je vais même jusqu'à
ouvrir ma maison en touraine à amboise
aux artistes pour organiser une
exposition d'art contemporain
raul il note comme c'est un vrai succès
parce que non seulement les initiés
viennent mais la boulangère
le paysan et c'est ça ce qui m'intéresse
la rencontre de différents mondes ces
échanges qui se créent dans mon salon
c'est à ce moment que la citation de
robert filliou l'art est ce qui rend la
vie plus intéressante que l'art prend
tout son sens pour moi et j'ai envie
d'aller plus loin
alors je repense à mon enfance à
l'impact qu'aurait pu avoir les oeuvres
d'art sur ma vie c'est pas forcément in
et pousser la porte d'une galerie de
rentrer dans un musée et c'est là que
commence l'aventuré du musée mobile
je vais aller à la rencontre de
différents artistes
adam khel king architectes américains
qui travaillent les containers il fait
avec ces containers des écoles des
orphelinats et je lui demande de créer
un espace d'exposition pour créer cette
exposition mobile et itinérante
il s'avère qu'il est à paris pour une
année sabbatique et commence ses croquis
je pars ensuite à la rencontre des
artistes aux quatre coins du monde de
scotland au fin fond de la chine à los
angeles à los angeles je rends compte
paul mccarthy
paul mccarthy est un artiste américain
qui à travers ses sculptures critique la
société américaine il me dit que lui
quand il était jeune il exposait sur les
parkings des supermarchés et qu'il aime
cette idée d'aller vers un public
différent je vais à flagstaff rencontré
james tueur l artiste américain
je le rencontre dans son cratère c'est
un artiste qui travaille la lumière
quand vous rentrez dans ses oeuvres
c'est une vraie expérience vous avez
cette sensation d'infini d'illimité il
me dit lui que petit il a été en contact
avec la musique classique et qu'il est
persuadé que l'art peut influer sur les
vies alors c'est comme ça que le musée
mobile va voir le jour à saint venant
nous allons à la rencontre des enfants
d'école primaire puisque c'est à cet âge
là qu'on nous apprend les fondamentaux à
lire à écrire à compter et il est tout
aussi important nous apprendre à rêver à
imaginer à se connecter avec nos
émotions
alors nous prenons la carte de france
pour tracer notre périple
et en fait on se rend compte qu'il ya un
vrai déséquilibre entre les villes et
les campagnes
la culture à la ville et la culture des
champs grâce au musée mobile
nous allons aller toucher ces publics
éloignés nous travaillons en
collaboration avec atd quart monde et
l'unesco
je me remémore une étape à saint denis
organisé par atd quart monde où nous
avons mélangé un groupe d'enfants la
moitié était de deux cités rivales
ils ne se parlaient plus ou alors pour
s'insulter au cours de la visite ils ont
commencé à échanger sans même s'en
rendre compte
autour de l'art l'art à ce pouvoir de
faire bouger des lignes ou alors à
marseille à la cité des aygalades là ce
sont les enfants qui ont fait la visite
à leurs parents à leurs grands-parents
aux copains aux habitants du quartier
puisque au delà des barrières
géographiques
il ya des barrières
écologique social et ses enfants nous
ont dit que les parents ne voulaient pas
les emmener au musée parce qu'il pensait
pas avoir les codes ou pas être assez
intelligent pour leur expliquer les
oeuvres d'art c'est ça l'expérience du
musée mobile au delà de la rencontre
avec les oeuvres de la pratique
artistique avec nos ateliers
il ya une vraie dimension sociale c'est
tout le quartier les habitants qui sont
invités à échanger autour de l'art en
fin de semaine nous organisons des
petits vernissage les enfants exposent
leurs créations et c'est assez
intéressant parce que souvent les
instituteurs découvre certains élèves
car souvent ce ne sont pas forcément les
premiers de la classe qui s'intéressent
le plus au musée mobile et cela ouvre le
champ des possibles quand vous faites
une exposition dans un container
forcément vous avez envie de la faire
voyager
nous sommes allés au cameroun et en côte
d'ivoire
alors là vous pourriez me dire allez en
afrique peut-être ça aurait été mieux
d'apporter des produits de première
nécessité eh bien non notre action a été
saluée déjà de les traiter d'égal à égal
d'apporter un projet qui a circulé en
france qui circulent en afrique et
surtout de la rapporter une boîte à
penser je me rappelle cette petite fille
à douala il faisait 40 degrés dehors
en sortant du muy mots et notamment de
l'oeuvre de james turrel elle nous a dit
merci pour cette fraîcheur
j'ai été au ciel au paradis j'ai
découvert des choses que je ne
connaissais pas ou alors à bouaké en
côte d'ivoire un pays où prendre la
parole librement est considéré comme mal
polis les enfants ont pu s'exprimer
exprimé leur émotion à travers ses
oeuvres
alors après six années d'expérimentation
de voyages de rencontres nous avons été
lauréats de la france s'engage voilà
comment un projet à la base un peu fou
utopique rentrer dans les politiques
publiques
c'est à dire que nous allons dupliquer
nos camions pour faire circuler les
hommes des collections nationales en
région
l'art le musée mobile a contribué à
donner du sens à ma vie
alors j'ai envie de vous dire engagez
vous croyez en vos idées le monde ne
bouge que si l'on rêve j'espère que mon
engagement pour l'éducation artistique
et culturelle aidera nos futurs citoyens
à habiter poétiquement la terre merci
[Applaudissements]